there's lots of ways to incorporate
self-care and to become more Zen in the
chaos you just need to put yourself as a
priority and even put it in your diary
like in your calendar as a schedule like
schedule in half an hour like go and get
a facial go for a walk you've got your
child's soccer or baseball you know
you've got to do those things right and
you never miss them so why don't you
make your appointments just as important
it came down to because I just really
wanted to feel well and I wasn't well I
was early 20s I wasn't looking after
myself I took a trip to Thailand plenty
of partying I came home with parasites
and Dengue Fever soon after I got home I
had a lot of sort of like female issues
and I went to the gynecologist and I had
a pap smear done and I had pre-cancerous
cells they said that I would potentially
struggle to get pregnant in the future
I'm 22 years old telling me that I might
struggle to have kids and that just
switched me and I was like I need to do
something that's really when I
discovered plant-based eating and I just
every day I just felt better and better
and it just sort of put me on this
journey of like wow like there is a
better version of me in here and I'm
just gonna keep going then I got
pregnant with Rowdy
[Music]
that was Lonnie Jean a mother creative
artist photographer and online content
creator living in Australia who's been a
close friend of mine since our oldest
children were just toddlers I truly
admire Lonnie and have been wanting to
get her on my podcast since the creation
of this podcast because she's just so
dang inspiring contemplative nuanced and
big-hearted we stay connected on and off
over the phone and I'm so happy to be
sharing a glimpse of our conversations
with you today Lonnie lives her passions
and thrives on vibrant simple living
across all aspects of her life from
healthy plant-based eating to staying
grounded in family to getting her
explant surgery and following her
intuition to self-care skin care
individuality and creative flow there's
something for everyone in this
conversation that is sure to light a
fire within you we cover her health
Journey from sick to thriving and not
taking care of herself to valuing her
health and wellness her breast implant
illness story what grounds her and
balancing work life and motherhood the
problems with social media and pressures
that come with it overcoming Anxiety
following your heart and her self-care
advice and more I didn't want to end
this conversation we always can talk for
hours and hours I hope you enjoy it
welcome to the Ellen Fisher podcast
welcome to the podcast Lonnie I'm so
excited to have you here and yeah just
so excited for this conversation thanks
for being here I'm so excited too well
and let's let's put our conversation out
to the world or the many ones that we've
had so I'm super excited to chat with
you and chat with everyone who's
listening
let's let's get it happening yeah a lot
of people who might be listening might
not know that we have been friends for a
long time we have been online friends
that's how we found each other but
Lonnie and her family has come to visit
Hawaii and we've got to spend part of
her vacation or her vacation while she's
here and we have gone to waterfalls
together I even have this beautiful
picture that she took because she's an
amazing photographer up in my home where
we're just sitting at a waterfall
together while I'm pregnant with Sandy
so this was like seven years ago and I
just find you so inspirational in so
many ways I love how authentic you are
even when it's tempting to not be
authentic you know there's so many
pressures and
I don't know ways to just convince
yourself to not be authentic but you
always stay true to yourself and I think
that's one reason why so many people are
so inspired by you
um just to finish tooting a little bit
your horn sitting a little bit when I
post on my Instagram stories people were
so excited I said I'm gonna interview
Lonnie Jane on the podcast and people
were so excited to hear from you and had
so many questions that they wanted me to
ask so yeah I'm just excited to get into
this well I appreciate all those sweet
words Ellen you're so kind and I feel
exactly the same way about you and I
think that's why we've been friends for
such a long time we have a lot in common
but we're also able to talk about our
differences and I just love just you
know being authentic in our friendship
and being authentic online and just
authentic and the people that we are so
um yeah I'm excited for this
conversation yeah yeah totally that's
like the only way I can have a
friendship and the fact that when we go
on the phone together we could just talk
for so long with the kids in the
background even and yeah
I know about all different kinds of
things so I guess but first let's just
Jump Right In and the first like thing
when I think of you is like inner
vibrancy
um being your authentic self while also
you manage to maintain this wonderful
balance in your life and I know a lot of
people like they see you have this
wonderful self-care routine that's so
inspiring and then you're also this
incredible mom so how do you find
balance in your life that feels good to
you
otter I think I think that's always
right the goal is to like find the
balance but I don't I don't ever feel
like I've ever perfectly got it in in
Balance like I think it's the juggle is
you know that's the whole point of it is
just the effort that it takes and as
long as you're always making effort to
try and create balance and that
equilibrium in life that's where you
will find the best balance that you
possibly can in what you have handed to
you
um you know I think
just in general it comes down to values
and I think like I've done a lot of um
value assessing over you know the past
sort of decade and I think my value like
one of my highest values is is sort of
vibrancy in general I want to feel good
I want to feel healthy I want my family
to live a good life and I sort of think
when when most decisions that I make
come from that foundational value of
feeling well living well
that that's
the main goal is really just you know
what what can I do to make myself feel
better what can I do here to improve my
family life what can I do
um to you know improve my relationship
with other friends family partner Etc so
I really think yeah the value one of my
greatest values is
is wellness and health so
that's really what it comes down to
so in term you know so when I'm thinking
like when I'm super busy and you know
I'm stressed out I'm like I sort of
asked myself like what could I do to
like bring myself back to my body you
know if I'm really stuck in my head so
maybe I'll just have a 20 minute sauna
maybe I'll just jump in the bath maybe
I'll do a face mask maybe I'll
maybe I'll go and just put my feet on
the grass
you know and when you're really busy I
think you know food is a huge one
especially when you know you're out on
the road or you're working it's so easy
to think oh yeah well I'll just go
through the drive through I'll just you
know go into the fast food store and
grab that because it's so convenient but
because my value is is sort of feeling
well I know that I need to prepare
before I I go and do those things so
I'll always put you know like some
tamari almonds and I'll leave them in my
car I'll grab a bunch of bananas on the
way so I can have snacks I'll pre-make
my food you know before I go out so
I think just really determining what
your values are
um really shapes you as a person and it
helps you really understand who you are
so yeah
yeah I think that's so on point because
whatever you're wherever your focus is
that's where you're gonna that's the
direction you're gonna head in so
whatever your biggest values are you're
going to make it a priority yeah and one
of the biggest things that actually
helped me really
really where I'm I'm sure you've
probably heard of him but Dr D martini
and he had oh you've not okay yeah he's
great he has a whole method of how to
determine what your values are so it
helps you sort of clarify your the
foundation of your life and then what
drives you
um like highly recommend it he's got a
program like just on his website I think
it's free actually I think that was the
first thing I did when I found out when
I when I discovered him he has a lot of
videos on YouTube he's got a podcast
um he's sort of like super old school
guy but he come his story actually
starts in Hawaii I think and
um he was like homeless and he couldn't
read or write
um he had no family and he was like
living in a tent and he was like really
sick and anyway I don't know this oh I
think it was the guy who started Braggs
you know the apple cider yeah he he
discovered he found him in this tent
and then literally like told him that
you know like you need to put yourself
together and like you can do and be
whatever you want he's like no but I
can't read or write and I'm dumb and I'm
stupid and he and I forget his name is
it John Bragg no anyway he really
instilled this belief to believe in
himself and that he could be whatever he
wants to be he just needs to set his
mind to it and to to to determine his
values
um and so that's sort of where it all
came from him and now he teaches
globally about how to
um sort of rate your value system and
what even values are and then how they
determine how your life will unfold
depending on what values that you have
so
uh yeah so it's super interesting so
I've learned a lot from him and yeah I
know that obviously one of my highest
values is health and wellness and then
family and um that's sort of like my two
biggest ones that's amazing I'm gonna
check this guy out because I love that
core foundational message for sure
I'm surprised I'm surprised you hadn't
but yeah I think you'll love him that's
so cool where is he living now
um I think he's from California but he's
always traveling he's just always doing
talks and seminars and live interviews
and all sorts of stuff he's just so
passionate about teaching people about
this just because of how much it turned
his life around and he was you know
dyslexic he couldn't read write or
anything and now he's written multiple
books
um and he speaks obviously every day so
it's amazing super inspirational that's
so cool so those core values of like
your wellness and then also your family
how you even balance that because
sometimes that can feel overwhelming
because like your children are your life
right and you really do have to make it
an extra priority to take care of
yourself or else it's so easy for
mothers and parents in general to put
their own self-care on the back burner
because like Andrew and I we got away
for two nights was it two nights yeah
two nights recently and oh my gosh we
were like a completely different couple
like it was like all it was like all we
could focus on each other for just a
couple of days and it made it was so
helpful for our relationship so how do
you not get like caught up in just the
chaos that sometimes happened in
motherhood and also like Center yourself
in the midst of that
I do I do definitely get caught up in
the chaos and I get overwhelmed just
like everyone else I think I've just
practiced
well I think I just continue to practice
that self-care self-love and that time
alone to even if it's just I think
people have a notion that you need hours
or days whereas
I see it as like minutes or you know an
hour it's you know if you can get days
great but most moms you just don't get
to have days uh even when they're at
school it's like you you're so busy
either working you know doing housework
keeping a household running a kitchen
Etc that there is lack of time to go and
lay around at the day spa or whatever or
you know sit for hours and read books
and do those sorts of things so I think
if you just incorporate the time into
the chaos like the five minutes to walk
on the grass with bare feet 10 minutes
to sit in the sun between you know work
um or screen time whatever it is like
um you know obviously I do have certain
luxuries at home that I've worked really
hard to get and set up like having a
sauna at home having beautiful
natural space that I can enjoy but you
know that that's that's where it comes
back to my values like I created this
space because those things are such a
high value to me and it was it's just
it's like a
um not it's like a non-compulsory I mean
it's like a compulsory thing for me like
I need to have those things for my life
to function well
I live a very busy life I think a lot of
people think oh I'm just so chill and
I'm like just sitting at home and you
know amongst the trees and the birds
and I do do a lot of those things but
it's it's just a mess in between the
chaos like you said like I've got you
know I run like I run a kitchen I
literally
have to have enough food at all times to
feed four people I mean you know the
drill like you've got even more people
in your household
um I do it on my own it's just the way
that our family Dynamic is and you know
my partner is off away working a lot of
the time so
you know in between I just yeah just
take those five ten minutes in between
and just make the most of it and just
really try and clear my head I Journal a
lot too I do a lot of journaling to get
instead of projecting onto other people
like if I'm frustrated with things or
I'm just can't quite work through
something
I just write it down
you know so um
there's lots of ways to incorporate
self-care and to become more Zen in the
chaos you just need to put yourself as a
priority and even put it in your diary
like in your calendar as a schedule like
schedule in half an hour like go and get
a facial go for a walk you know go to
watch the sunrise like just like you
would oh you've got a chill you've got
your child's
soccer or baseball you know you've got
to do those things right and you never
miss them so why don't you make your
appointments just as important
we're brought to you today by a favorite
Apothecary shop of mine called anima
Mundi herbals they specialize in high
potency elixirs medicinal mushrooms and
collagen boosters and support true Fair
Trade Practices Beyond organic farming
education and small farmers to create
remedies that benefit people from all
walks of life I love the immunity
boosters in their shop including black
elderberry syrup mushroom mocha milk and
spirulina which is an organic
protein-rich mineralizer that tastes
delicious in banana mango smoothies I'm
also obsessed with their happiness
powder and energizing and mood boosting
herbal coffee that is caffeine free and
adaptogenic The Organic roasted
dandelion root is one of the key
elements that give this powder a
coffee-esque flavor while also
stimulating the liver and supporting
healthy digestion and the body's natural
detoxification process much like coffee
it has a pleasant roasted flavor with
bitter notes making it a perfect powder
for all coffee lovers looking to boost
their mood while improving their health
also when I was pregnant I loved their
goddess magic healing and moisturizing
bundle which includes a collagen booster
face oil Loom tea blue lotus flowers and
a rose body oil which is just a Vine
anema Mundi uses eco-friendly packaging
in recyclable glass or biodegradable
bags I'm a huge fan of supporting a Nema
Mundi herbals and I got an awesome
discount for you guys so use my code
ln15 for 15 off anything at
nemamundiherbals.com that's
a-n-i-m-a-m-u-n-d-i-h-e-r-b-a-l-s.com
that's such a good point there's a lot
of things you said there that I think
are really valuable because I recently
did a Financial Freedom episode with
this really awesome woman named Rachel
Cruz she's Dave Ramsey's daughter I
don't know if you know who that is
um but we didn't I think I've heard of
her yeah and so we did an episode on on
Financial Freedom and one of those
aspects is like
um sacrificing in areas where you can
cut costs but then also like I was
mentioning how that doesn't mean you
have to sacrifice in every area so
whatever is your highest value you're
gonna be willing to save for and work
hard for to be able to get that so like
for us we've been sharing one car for 10
years and that's like worth it for us
and something we're able to manage so
far but I don't know how much longer
we're gonna manage with that like with
all the sports as the kids are getting
older and now a fifth child so but so
far that's something do we have a bus
do you have a bus for all your kids I
know really a mum Ikea Carnival isn't it
I know we might be we might be upping
our game soon in the largeness of the
car that we get but just like pointing
out that like there were certain there's
certain areas that are worth it to us to
like sacrifice in order to be able to
spend more on something like quality
food and for you that's like a sauna and
different things like that so I think
that is really an awesome point and then
just the other factor of making your own
time just as much of a priority as it is
for your kids and like that can be
really hard because sometimes it's like
you really want to focus on giving your
kids enough love and attention and time
but then if you're not taking care of
yourself in between those moments then
you can get really burnt out then you're
not going to be as great of a mom as you
could be
yeah yeah I think too I really felt this
when I got unwell and I really struggled
to be like to look after my family the
way that I always had
um you know not being able to get out of
bed like you know most every morning I'm
up 4 45 5 a.m and I just couldn't I
couldn't get out of bed I didn't I had
sore head I had headaches
um my fatigue was insane so I just
didn't feel well enough but you know and
I know that a lot of people really
struggle with that like
if their value isn't health or feeling
well and they're just constantly feeling
terrible then you just can't really
apply yourself to be the best person for
someone else
absolutely absolutely and that's one of
those reasons where I've also found the
same as you that like making my health a
priority it makes everything else fall
into place because when I'm feeling
really good I can mentally and
physically I can be a better parent a
better partner and enjoy my life more
yeah just so much more energy and yeah
you just don't have to worry about
feeling
unwell or I've got a headache today or
I've got a sore belly or like I'm
dealing with these huge health problems
and burden other people with it
unintentionally
if you just apply that effort to eating
well and taking those small steps out of
your day to
um ground yourself and clear your head
and a little bit of pampering time if it
fits it just it just makes all the
difference you know yeah and even if
that means like 30 minutes after the
kids go to bed which tends to be my time
that I'm able to like give myself some
me time like some skin care time and
like relaxation that is in and of itself
and being intentional with that time
when you're alone instead of you know
trying to pass the time or just put on a
TV and just you know zone out and Escape
um I'm not saying that I haven't done
that or there's times that I don't want
to do that but for the majority of the
time when I'm not with the kids I like
to
do so many things like I I don't want to
escape who I am when I'm alone like I
want to be with me I want to spend time
with me because I I like this person
that I have created and I like being in
my head and like because I'm not in my
head I'm like
when I'm super healthy and I'm feeling
great like I'm nice to myself and I I am
so creative and all these things come to
me and I want to work and I want to just
become a better person so I don't need
to escape in a television show or on
social media like getting lost in
someone else's life because I love
myself and I love my life yeah and
that's inspiring there's nothing wrong I
know a lot of people sorry I know a lot
of people watch lots of you know Netflix
series and I I've watched you know
plenty of them myself but I think I the
difference is I don't use it as like an
escape to like oh I wish my life was
like that or just to not think about
where my life is at and just get
distracted in the show
um if anything I get distracted myself
distracts me from when I'm watching that
stuff I'm like I've got other things to
do like I can't this is I'm wasting my
life yeah there's a big difference
between like quality time with your
partner maybe to watch a movie versus
like zoning out in front of the TV and
like wasting a lot of the precious time
that you have
yeah for sure
so can you talk a little bit about your
health journey and why and when you
became passionate about your health like
maybe walk us through a little bit about
like your plant-based journey and when
you started just caring about your
Wellness
yeah
um so I think the same thing as the
values thing
um it came down to because I just really
wanted to feel well and I wasn't well
um and I think I had this real drive to
like
just just feel my best like surely
there's a better version of me in here
so um it was I was early 20s and I just
moved Interstate up to Queensland from
Melbourne on my own and I wasn't looking
after myself I took a trip to Thailand
plenty of partying and you know all the
fun stuff but I came home with parasites
and dengue fever
and I was just so sick like they didn't
even want to leave me on the uh send me
home on the plane they were like you're
not well enough to to be on this flight
and I was like just took a heap of you
know painkillers I'm like I'm fine I'm
fine like I just wanted to get home
um so that was really the Catalyst and I
think soon after I got home I had a lot
of sort of like
female issues and I went to the
gynecologist and I had a pap smear done
and I had pre-cancerous cells and hbv
and they said that
my hormones were all over the place and
I would potentially struggle to get
pregnant in the future
and I just was like
that's I'm 22 years old like I you're
telling me that I might struggle to have
kids like I I can't take that as
as a fact right now like it's and that
just switched me and I was like I need
to do something and that's really when I
discovered plant-based eating and you
know I went down in the deep end and
just did the raw food lifestyle for six
months six to 12 months
I did a huge juice cleanse to start with
it was about four weeks long
and I just every day I just felt better
and better
and it just sort of put me on this
journey of like
wow like there is a better version of me
in here and I'm just gonna keep going
so um
then that was the same time that there
was
Instagram came out
and I naturally because I was always
taking photos like I was a photographer
before so
I was always using Facebook and sharing
a lot of my life on Facebook and you
know downloading a whole Gallery you
know after a weekend
right so naturally just got
just got on Instagram and then just
started sort of documenting
just naturally just documenting my story
because even if you go right back you
can see all my partying days and then
the way that I used to eat back then and
then just sort of like this slow
transition into
a different lifestyle
so that was
that was sort of how it all started and
I just kept going with it I just kept
feeling better and better
and I and then my hormones obviously
balanced out my gut issues balanced out
my skin issues balanced out
and then I got pregnant with Rowdy
I was surprised because
they told me that I would struggle
and I had just got off I had an implant
on I don't know if you had that in the
states it's like a contraception that
you put in your arm
and I had that removed and
I was pregnant within six months and
they said it's it'll take you years
probably if you do if you are able to
get pregnant
so yeah I was a little bit surprised
when I got pregnant but I was so happy
like I was just like yes like my body
can do this
what a gift you know I did it you know I
I healed myself with obviously the help
you know once I got pregnant I was like
wow like this lifestyle really is doing
amazing things for me and my body so I'm
just gonna keep going and it's just been
sort of one one thing to another
and I was pretty much just on a roll for
well a solid eight years and then I got
struck down with breast implant illness
um which just took me it felt like you
know 10 steps backwards I felt worse
than what I felt in my early 20s
it was so rapid and so fast it was sort
of come on like end of 2019 and then
2020 it was like
I just went downhill so fast I couldn't
really fully figure it out because
obviously 2020 was hectic for everyone
I thought maybe it was just an anxiety
thing I thought it was
just it was so it was so many things
that happened that year
but I couldn't also ignore the pain that
I had in my left side
um obviously my chest but all down my
arm I had numbness I had pain I felt
like I was having a heart attack
honestly like a lot of the time wow and
that was that was mainly from the
capsular contracture so the scar tissue
got so tight and so thick and restricted
because it was connected to my rib cage
it was pulling like on all of those
nerve endings
so I couldn't this is pretty much how
how I could lift my arm
because it was just tight it was like
trying to protect my body from that
implant that was leaking
um and just getting this that scar
tissue just getting super tight so
um when did you get your yeah
so I got I can't remember the exact year
I'm thinking it was like
2010 or 11.
so I was sort of coming up to like
nearly 10 years like 9 10 years so I
think I started I feel like they started
leaking around year eight
or nine
and
yeah but I didn't know they were leaking
the MRIs didn't come up and they said
they were clear my many doctors said you
should just keep them in get your
money's worth there's nothing wrong with
them like it's in your head
you know there's no there's no such
thing as breast implant illness it's
just silly it's a made-up thing and I
was like
yeah like and this was a lot of
professionals like chiropractors
osteopaths naturopaths uh Chinese
acupuncturists
um herbal like a herbalist a general
practitioner gynecologist like because I
had gone to a lot of different people
like prior to sort of like six to 12
months before just trying to figure out
what was going on
so
yeah no one found the lake until it was
I was cut open and it was removed and my
surgeon said he's like you were right
like your left one was leaking it's
yellow it's like sticky and oozing
and it's probably been leaking into your
bloodstream for however long
that must have been a little bit of a
relief to know that like your intuition
was right
yeah it was a validation to be honest I
was like
it really validated the fact that like
my intuition is very strong and I can
hear it so loudly
um it was just hard to hear it like 2020
because obviously there was just so much
going on
and I just couldn't get in tune like
fully with myself
I was just so empathetic for so many
other people and everything that was
going on around me that I just couldn't
hear it you know
but yeah when he did validate that I was
like oh I knew it I just knew it
and I had said that openly too on
Instagram I said
this was Prior like I said oh I'm not
feeling well guys I just want to be
transparent like I'm just not myself
I feel like there might be something
going on with my left implant I'm not
sure the MRI everything says it's fine
but I just feel like it's not right
so yeah it was good it was just so good
to get them out
so good and then what's been the result
since you got them out
oh just a general
incline of well like health and wellness
I just feel like I'm just finally
getting back to myself if not like a
better version of myself like prior to
even when I felt well like when I had
the implants I just think I've never
you know I was in denial for a long time
like with the implants I
kind of just stop seeing them as not a
part of me like when you have them for
so long you
that's just the image of that's who you
see in the mirror I don't wake up every
day going oh yeah I've got two plastic
silicon
objects under my skin like you just
don't think about that you know and I
think I just blocked it out because like
I was also breastfeeding a lot of those
years
and obviously the last thing you want to
do as a mother is like
think you're like putting toxins into
your children or yourself you know and I
was it was it's a it was looking at it
now like it's obviously a huge
contradiction to what I was
what my lifestyle was about
um but I'm like I can see that and I can
openly criticize myself that it
definitely was and
um you know that's just what the Journey
of life is like you live and you learn
and you move forward and you become a
better person and you learn from those
hard lessons
right and I think that's one reason why
people can like learn so much from you
and do learn so much from you or be or
am inspired by you because you share how
you like start digging deep into this
topic that you're like finding like
really important for you at the moment
and you'll just dig and dig and dig and
dig until you can't find anything else
anymore and that's why actually your
ebooks are probably my favorite ebooks
definitely my favorite ebooks I've ever
read they like you can just tell that
you put so much work into every topic
and really researching for yourself
because like you said you went to all
these different all different types of
practitioners and you're being told this
thing and your intuition just knew that
like no this is no there's something
more to this and so and then you were
right and so I think that's something
that a lot of people can learn from too
that like to really really dig deep into
whatever the topic is at hand whether
for you it was like sauna use or breast
implant illness or just your over
overall health or like a specific
symptom you're experiencing and so
anyone listening definitely check out
her ebooks because you go super into
depth and I mean it's true you go super
into depth into a lot of these topics
like
um about your wellness and stuff and so
that is something that I feel is really
inspiring and how you just kept digging
about your breast breast implant illness
and now you're seeing yeah I mean once I
started digging though wow like the
amount of women that are sharing their
stories
about the same thing that I had I was
like how have I not heard about this
like how how have I not seen this like
this is
this is insane like this is just
like of course this is what's causing my
health like once I saw it I saw it like
I was like 100 like this is it you know
um so you know I that's why I felt
really called to continue to share like
my journey through it I just like to be
transparent and you know I think I
started so Raw on this on Instagram
that I never felt the need to try and
create like this Persona or this image
of myself
as a as something I just
am that person I just became that person
through sharing it for so many I mean
it's been over a decade now
um I think it'd be pretty easy to tell
like if I wasn't authentic or if I was
trying to be fake or create stories or
or an image of myself that I'm not
so I just always just try and remember
that like I'm just like everyone else I
go through hardships as we all do I go
through challenges but I think what how
I like to view them is just it's just a
lesson like it's just a challenge it's
just something to overcome and you know
if you can overcome it yourself and
learn something from it by sharing it
you can also help teach other people and
give them insight and awareness about
something they may not have any idea
about totally so then how do you go
about deciding how much of what you're
learning should be guided by research
versus your intuition
yeah I think it's balanced I think
I think there's such a good mix of the
two I think initially it comes up as an
intuitive uh guidance an intuitive
message
um sometimes the way things come to me
it's like
it's just feels like it's like someone's
telling me
um
but that's what I need to hear or that's
what I need to look into
you can call it Spirit you can call it
guides I'm not I don't even know I just
know that I can hear it I know I can
feel it and it's something that I've had
since I was very young
I still remember the time when I was in
school in primary school and I used to
this might sound a bit wee-woo I haven't
shared this much at all but
I always knew that there was something
else other than just like this physical
body and this physical knowledge because
I used to be able to see like
um like this spinning kind of like aura
that would
just keep spinning around me and it was
like these tiny little dots like a
little bit like static you know like on
a TV when you see static but it's got
like these little Rainbow flecks in it
it was kind of like that and it just
would I could see it and I could kind of
tune into it and I could just see it
kind of moving and then I don't know it
just
I think being able to just like slow
down and like realize that there's so
much more than just this physical body
allowed me
and gave me that skill to like hear
messages from myself even or from
ancient wisdom who knows you know
so definitely my intuition is usually
what triggers me to think about
something or want to know about
something
but also challenging
uh General beliefs and the general
system the way that things work and the
way that the general people
believe
um
I just like to see what else there is I
like to deeply understand things and
I'll go to the depths of like
is this clear like is this a clear
message of like
it's this way or it's that way you know
I'm just I'm just not a black and white
person I just think there's so many gray
areas in everything
and an array of colors
so I just like to just dig as deep as I
can I like to talk to a lot of people
about their experiences
um I like to journal a lot and then
yeah I'll go down many Avenues to find
information about things especially with
health
like I'm not the kind of person just to
go I believe in doctors right like I
love doctors I think that they are great
very experienced very knowledgeable but
there's kind of is a bit of a limit
because
they're not looking at an intuitive
aspect they're not looking at
um you know messages that might just
come through
they just think that that's just not
even an option
um just like with the breast implants
you know I said
I just don't I just don't think they're
right you know and they're like they're
fine like we've scanned them
there's nothing wrong yeah like if I
took that I'd still be sitting here I'd
probably I'd be so sick like
you know and and like how many people go
through even just the medical system and
they things go wrong like
you can't take everything as like these
as fact from the from the experts like
anyone you know if there's something
niggling inside you and you think no
like that's a gut feeling that's a
Instinct and you should act on it yeah
there's a like so much that we can learn
from medical practitioners but we also
have to like you said understand the
limits because even the practitioners
and doctors that I've interviewed so far
on the podcast will fully acknowledge
that the amount of nutrition that they
learn in medical school is little to
none like it's very they had to go they
had to go and research it themselves to
come to that conclusion so yeah taking
everything with a grain of salt the gray
is so important and I think when I'm
coming to a conclusion about something
being able to look at all sides like
what is every side saying because it's
really easy to get this tunnel vision
and be like this is the only answer
everything about this is the way I
cannot question anything but then you're
missing so many opportunities to learn
from other perspectives because it'll
either it'll either solidify your
perspective even more like no yeah I
definitely don't agree with that or I
don't I don't see that aspect for sure
or it'll help open up new avenues be
like oh I never considered it this way I
need to look into this and then you're
going to have a much easier time getting
to the truth that you're looking for or
not that you're looking for but the
truth at hand based on where you're
trying to go
yeah and uh you know in saying that
about truth like I think everybody's
truth is different and it depends on
where you are in your life it depends on
so many different things
so you know and in saying like about
getting
seeing perspectives like I I grew up the
youngest in a family of four
oh I've got three other siblings and um
you know a broken family at a very young
age
lots of emotional turmoil
and I think being a very observant
person that I am
I could see
so many different sides to
what was happening I could see
you know with siblings right you know
there's fights there's disagreements and
you have that with your parents and you
see that unfold with your parents like
with huge disagreements that they may
have and as a young child
you sort of like what's going on there
like
trying to digest it and um
I don't know I just think there's a lot
of like just gray there's so much gray
what someone might do is not necessarily
right or wrong to them and vice versa
yeah trying to understand each other is
like one of the core reasons why I
started this podcast because I love just
hearing the different perspectives and
just opening up that Avenue because it's
so easy to just go down this road where
you only listen to one like thought
process and I'm just I just don't like
that I just thought about it
so
okay so a question that's like a little
more specific that someone in my
Instagram asked me wanted me to ask you
actually I got multiple questions like
this what are five healthy daily habits
that you recommend people try to get
into and make sustainable
yeah okay
I okay well let's start with
the day before with getting enough sleep
um
there there has been so so many years
obviously being sleep deprived with
young babies and work and everything but
still just having that mindset like I
need to get to bed because sleep is
important and it just makes the next day
run so much more smoothly
and being a little bit more prepared
with your the night before like what am
I doing the next day what what is my
next what do I want my day to look like
how do I want my day to feel if you just
wake up in shambles and nothing's
nothing's clean nothing's organized you
just
you know you're just running a mat like
like a around like
crazy person then that's just what the
energy is going to feel so I think
getting enough sleep
trying to sort of get up around the same
time every day
is helpful because just just that
circadian rhythm I think is important
drinking good water
like if you're on town like tap water
get a good filter
get don't do not just don't drink that
stuff what filters
I've got it I've got a filter called
alkaway and it's it gets rid of like a
lot of like the sediment your chemicals
um it takes fluoride out of the water
and it's also I've got actually a few
different systems because I've got a UV
because we're on tank water
so I've got a UV light that kills
bacteria
um and things like that so just
good healthy water just try and always
filter your water through something
um I would probably say
set up a little space in your house
put a yoga mat down or a mat of some
kind of little rug with a pillow
Korea I always say like create a space
to create yourself
just
like a dedicated space just for you and
take five minutes if that's all you have
and just
all you need to do is just get on the
map you don't have to go I need to do
this yoga session I need to do this many
poses I need to do this many squats or
it's not even just about working out
it's just about being like in your body
in that space
just allowing yourself that time to be
with yourself
so create a space all you need is just a
mat a pillow some headphones if you've
got them if it's just a block out noise
um if it's behind closed doors that's
great because if you have kids you know
you don't want them climbing all over
you
um and I would probably say
going outside between work
kids
parenting anything that you're doing
even if the weather's terrible just go
outside for at least five to ten minutes
put your feet on the grass put your son
in the put your skin in the Sun
and it just it activates so many more
things than what we even know
um you know you know a lot about
earthing and grounding
and it just it might just look like
grass and bare skin but it does so much
energetically for your body
and the same with the Sun so and it's so
much more than just vitamin D
and it does so many amazing things for
your body so I would always recommend
don't be scared of the sun like just
give it five minutes you know if that's
all you've got
yeah I think I think that science has a
long way to go to understand
energetically what's happening to our
body when we do certain things like we
just don't even comprehend the energy
involved of everything because I'll even
have a few days where I'm like have a
ton of work to do and I just like am
inside on the computer all day three
days straight and then if I take a day
where i'm like wait I haven't gone
outside and I go step outside like the
difference that I feel in my body even
just for those 10 minutes where I'm like
what have I been missing because I'm
sitting staring at a screen trying to
get all this work done because I have
like deadlines or whatever different
things I'm trying to get done and then
if I step outside you feel such an
energetic difference in your physical
body in your mental health and a lot of
the things you just mentioned are very
um mental health I feel like wait did
you say four do you have one more to go
yeah
um what was the other thing I think
stretching of some any type of
stretching even if it's just a like just
get your back I have scoliosis so I
always stretch but I just think that
we're all
right we're at computers we're on our
phones we're driving like I just think a
general stretch just sort of like awaken
those like dark areas in your body that
tend to be stagnant and still for such
long periods of time like you know most
people I think it's like lower back neck
so like just just stretching it out like
take a few minutes to actually and if
you can do that with your bare feet on
the grass and looking at the sun
and having a drink of water like
there's your things combined and then
you if you just go okay five minutes
five times a day or I don't know you
know just go okay five minutes I'm just
gonna go and do five minutes stretch
have a drink of water look at the sun
even if it's just through the window
with your eyes like
and then what was the fourth fifteen
stretch the quality of water oh the
girls sleep and the sleep yeah yeah
that's like so
you can just combine a few of those
things and it's like it doesn't have to
be complicated to give you vibrancy it
doesn't have to be complicated to heal
you these are things that are just
gifted to us and you know the sun is not
a burden the sun is not going to kill
you the sun is not going to give every
person cancer that's you're not going to
get all these problems from the Sun like
we wouldn't even be here without the sun
we wouldn't even be here if we didn't
have fresh air and oxygen like
I think just like just immerse yourself
in it for a short amount of time and
you'll just see the beauty so much more
clearly like clearly and a lot of these
things are things that you can do with
your kids like your kids can go outside
and stretch with you and anyone yeah
if your partner's outside in the
driveway like cleaning the car or doing
something like all right well I'll just
go out hey do you want to join if they
don't then that's cool you still do it
like don't wait for other people if your
kids don't want to join in like just do
it because
and that's that's that's even better
like be the example you know I think the
more like when you just do it for
yourself that's how you inspire other
people to do the same
um because they see the difference that
it makes in you so
I just think that being well doesn't
have to be complicated it's just these
consistent continuous things that you do
throughout the day
throughout most days that make all the
difference what is it it's like all the
small things that add up it's not this
one big thing that you do it's all of
the small things you do on a daily
occurrence absolutely and like I was
saying a lot of those things you
mentioned are very mental health related
so how have you found like looking back
in your life like what did you envision
for your life before you thought you
would do what you do now and I know that
you're not really doing like um as much
social media work
um as you do now or as you did before
um but when you look at like the
problems with social media and mental
health and I would love to talk to you
about that you just got back from a
retreat that was super really really
good for your wellness and for your mind
so maybe you could share a little bit
about your thoughts about like what you
think the problems are with social media
that you've seen on your personal level
yeah
um yeah I've not only seen it I've I've
felt it on a very deep level
um very direct towards me so
um and it was at a very vulnerable time
in my life where I was really struggling
with my mental health as a lot of people
were which is I think why it was even
worse because we had all of these messed
up people online that were hurting
themselves and they just wanted to
project out to other people and um we
still have that
we still have that I don't think it ever
goes away yeah there's so many hurting
people
um and then I'm only hurting people yeah
yeah
um
so I think
why I said those sort of five things is
because that's what I really
sort of solidified during my time of my
struggle with my mental health and my
decline in my mental health I had like
debilitating anxiety I didn't want to
leave the house I didn't want to I
couldn't even log in I couldn't even
open my phone like everything was just
triggering to me like I would feel
physically sick I would even sometimes
even physically be sick I would have
panic attacks
um I could even putting the TV on like I
couldn't watch any of the news
um I couldn't talk to people because
they would always talk about all of the
bad things happening in the world
um
honestly everything triggered me it was
it was a terrible time in my life and
this was like end of night end of 2019
and then the whole of 2020 it was
um I think the main thing that triggered
it was
my health my breast implants they
've never experienced anxiety to that
depth I don't even think I'd experience
anxiety like
until then you know when people are like
I've got anxiety and back when I never
knew what it was I was like I'm sorry
like is there anything I could do for
you but I just didn't understand it
whereas now I've been through it I'm
like oh well like no wonder these people
can't leave their houses no wonder they
can't get out of bed
and no wonder they just shut everybody
out because it's just such an internal
battle
so
continually to try and practice those
things throughout that mental health
Journey for me just all just slowly just
brought me back into my body instead of
just being stuck in my head just slowly
just like every time I would go and sit
in the Sun or I would just have a good
drink of water or I would have a better
sleep I would feel better so I'm like
these are the little things I need to
keep practicing and if that's all that I
can do that's that's all I'm gonna do
if if for the most part of the day I'm
going to be in bed but I just take
you know every uh few hours I just go
out and just do those things then I'm
going to be better by the end of the day
than I was
in the in the morning you know what I
mean
um so yeah so what was happening what
was happening on social media at that
time for you
yeah so
okay I'll start back like 2019 Okay so
I was obviously unwell
I was unaware that I had my implants
were leaking at the time they were
causing a decline in my health and my
mental health
but at the same time we had horrific
bushfires start in Australia and very
close to my home all around the
mountains in the bush area around here
it was there was smoke for months it was
terrible it got very bad around the end
of December started January 2020.
and then also my partner had a really
terrible motorbike accident
uh at the on at the end of December not
2019 and that spiraled me down even
further
and then
Coronavirus
coronavirus hit
January it was a couple of days after my
birthday
and it was the first time I heard of it
I was on vacation in Hamilton Island and
I was like wow
what is this thing
um and then it went into
lockdowns and hectic restrictions
um a lot of fear-mongering about you
know you just didn't want to go outside
it was just Terror it was terrifying
um as everybody was in the same boat
right
um my health was declining further I got
terrible tooth
pain and like during like one of the
first lockdowns it was so sudden I just
was just doing something during the day
and it was just like both sides of my
mouth just went like
like someone just stabbed me in the jaw
like I was like oh my gosh like what is
that
what is that like
I didn't know what had just happened
I had to get like an emergency
appointment because nothing was open
so that just in itself was very eerie
feeling I was like walking into a
dentist right no one's there they
literally unlocked the door turn the
lights on and you're the only one
walking in I'm like
this is so weird
um and and then he's just like you have
this strange like nerve damage that's
come up from your jaw
and your nerves are dead
just on these same two teeth exactly the
same on either side
and your tooth is just died
and I was like what do you mean like I
have regular checkups and he's like yeah
no this wasn't here last year like I
don't know what this is but we're gonna
have to extract those teeth wow and I
was like I'm gonna have to pull my teeth
out like is there nothing else you can
do and he's like no because of the nerve
is dead
there's nothing that you can do and I
was like but why is the nerve dead and
he's like I don't know like it's a very
strange thing wow fast forward a bit I
saw a Chinese a traditional Chinese
therapist and they said that the
Meridian that's connected to these teeth
runs directly down past the left breast
implant into the large intestine oh my
goodness so
the energy was blocked
and she said she seemed to think that
that's why I had
these two teeth just suddenly die
because of the meridian yeah
so I had those two extracted just me and
this dentist in a dark dentist office it
was horrible
um that was very painful
I I have a really bad reaction to pain
medication
and he put me on
um like messindol like this really high
pain medication and I had a terrible
reaction to that I got even worse
anxiety
um had a huge falling out with my family
around the same time I mean that's
traumatic in and of itself to like all
of a sudden have to have like two teeth
removed that you weren't expecting
amongst having all these other things
that's going on in your life and that is
traumatic in and of itself
let alone what you're saying keep going
about your family
yeah and uh we were obviously
homeschooling at the time like we were
in lockdown the kids were with us 24 7.
I know you're used to that but I was not
used to that just trying to keep on top
of everything and then just try and also
heal from these two gaping holes in my
jaw I couldn't eat properly I just it
was not a nice time and I was on these
this pain medic because I it was so
painful I just couldn't
get around it
um I ended up making my own cannabis oil
to try so I could get off the synthetic
pain medication and
try something more natural well
I obviously made myself something so
potent
I took too much
and I had a terrible experience
and that was sent me into another panic
attack it was just not nice it was
really not nice
[Music]
um
I had yeah a huge falling out with my
family I didn't see them then for
another year and
I didn't really talk to most of them
for a lot of that time too so it was
just a very isolated time for me to be
just in pain in in all areas
and then
the black lives matters movement
happened
um and I'm a very empathetic person I
felt so hurt by what these people were
going through
and I just tried to express that through
social media
and it wasn't received it was
like the opposite effect
I've never I don't think got I've got a
lot of abuse in my time through social
media I've done a lot of media things on
large channels but this was like
like the most nasty horrible
like threats towards myself and my
family and my children and
like people being like I know where you
live like I know I know where your kids
go to school like it was just
I'm like why like I I haven't I'm trying
to express
my sympathy and my gratitude like what
can I do to improve this what can I do
to help
and I just got attacked for it and I
think just with how sensitive I was at
the time yeah you were going through a
lot already I just I couldn't handle
like I
I I just completely shut down and I got
into this headspace thinking that I was
like I was like worthless and
what I was doing was just pointless and
who cares about what I'm doing like why
why have I got such a great life like
I just wanted to sabotage everything and
I did
sabotage a lot of
like many parts of my life
I guess because I I tried to bring
myself to those levels of those low
people that were trying to attack me
so that they wouldn't attack me right
like I'd be on their level like I
wouldn't be this this person that they
would feel the need to bring down
because I would already be down right
right
yeah so I'm sorry I took a few months
off you've gone through so much yeah
like especially like with your family
having that falling out on top of
everything with you not feeling well I'm
so sorry that you experienced that let
alone all at the same time
yeah uh it's a lesson right like I
learned so much about myself I learn a
lot about other people I that's really
how I like to look at it it was a lesson
I think I've grown a lot
it strengthened a lot of the bonds in my
life between other people and I have
mended you know we have mended those
relationships like between the family so
you know
um and everyone's sort of Taken
accountability that like
I think it was just a really heightened
sensitive time like the start of 2020
the whole of 2020 was just everyone was
just like at this like
at their limit of what they could
emotionally mentally physically take on
yeah not even I think naturally a lot of
people project
it out yes absolutely because you know
everything on the news they're talking
about the actual virus but not much was
actually talking about mental health
amongst all the lockdowns and everything
that was happening amongst that which
turns out years later they're finally
going oh actually yeah this caused a lot
of problems in this other ways as well
that wasn't being talked about before
yeah and I do want to mention you know
Ellen like you were such a support to me
during that time like I know that I was
a little bit quiet and that was just
because I just couldn't I couldn't deal
with I just didn't even I couldn't
digest anything properly like so but you
know you you had some great
conversations with me and I also know
that you were going through a hard time
with a lot of things so to be able to
relate together and support each other
through that was like I really
appreciate that too oh yeah I totally
remember that I remember like hiding in
the bathroom so that I could have like
fully focused on my conversation with
you I was like Andrew take the kids I
need to talk to my friend right now
they're like locking the bathroom door
and the kids are like on the door but
I'm like no I need to talk to Lonnie
right now I do remember that I know
yeah because you're just so open and you
just you can see things from
so many different sides and I really
needed someone
that could relate to me like someone
that was going through a hard time also
with certain things and someone that was
also on had a large following who had
been online sharing their life for a
long time
and
you know you're just so wise and you're
so thoughtful and caring that you just
you did really help me through that time
so I thank you so much for that oh
thanks slightly you're gonna make me cry
I like cried in my last episode and the
episode before that I'm like I'm not
gonna do it three times in a row
anyways because you're a sweet soul but
you're also pregnant yeah maybe that's
it but they were also heavy topics the
last couple ones and this is like this
is quite heavy too like anytime you're
going through some things like really
serious with your mental health and then
on top of it add on physical health and
on top of it family in your life like
and then on top of it social media
because I think a lot of people don't
realize like how damaging the social
media thing can be because it's a whole
it's a whole new fake world out there
where people say things they would never
say to someone in real life and yeah
it's just it's just gotten to this level
that's just kind of crazy to me so but I
don't even see it going in any other
direction for a long time if ever I
don't know
I'm the same and it just it just
solidifies that you just got to continue
you just got to go on and just keep
being authentic keep being yourself
you're not for everyone right like we're
not for everyone we don't need to be
liked by everyone and some people just
don't like anyone they just yeah they
just want to spread hate they don't even
like who they are so
you just I just take that on board I'm
like I just just stay true to who I am
and you know life is such a journey like
this social media things not just like
oh you just share for one day and then
that's it like that's all people see of
your life like we've been on this for
like over a decade and your life changes
you know it Ebbs and flows and you
change
yeah so
I just thought every time I get like
funny about posting or like oh I
shouldn't share this so I shouldn't
share that or
like I pull it apart
I just just try and just remind myself
that like this is just who I am at this
time and that's okay it doesn't matter
if someone doesn't like it they have the
option to leave
yes absolutely I was listening to this
something that Jay Shetty had said once
do you know who he is he's a kind of Big
Brother yeah and he was saying the
negative effects to like opening up your
phone the moment you wake up and pulling
up social media he's like this is
something that we would never do be able
to do before social media where you
basically open up your whole mind to
like a million people and yeah this is
for not for somebody with a following or
without a following it applies to
everybody anyone anybody you're taking
in everybody's opinions everybody's
thoughts about things that's just
getting put on social media and right
after you woke up in such a sensitive
time right it is it's such a spongy time
you like your brain is just like a
sponge but it needs to be focused on you
and what you need to do for the day what
you need to do for your family not
what's everyone else doing yeah or what
everyone else is thinking about you or
other people and whenever I've let
myself get into a place of like a spiral
because I've definitely gone to that
place where I've let other people
people's opinions affect how I feel
about myself like in when it's happening
in large quantities which has happened
you know multiple times and if I ever
let myself get to that place Andrew will
be like Ellen look just think about this
he's like picture a baseball stadium
every single person is filled in that
Stadium like however many thousands like
it's like 70 000 people like all those
people and they're all looking at you
like you're there's no way that you're
gonna get all of them to just understand
you or see it the way that you do like
you just that's just reality like all
think about all those people he's like
now times that by five and it's like
then you really picture the amount of
people and it's like you really just
have to let it go and be like you're
just gonna continue to do what feels
right and be authentic and at the same
time like let things go that like
everyone's gonna see life in a different
way and because of the way social media
is it just causes a lot of people to do
things that they would or say things
that they would never say in real life
and like that's just something that you
have to accept and then you can grow
from it
yeah yeah no I totally agree and with
the with the with the stadium analogy I
think right if you're in a stadium
there's usually two teams
and it they're arguing amongst
themselves for the most part so you know
it's just it's always going to be that
way you're just never gonna get
everybody's side and not everybody's
going to see what you did right and what
you did wrong and you just can't justify
it right like when you're in a in a game
of any kind in a stadium like you have
like one referee like or a few referees
telling the players it don't it's really
about what they saw and what how they
think like it's about what the referee
thinks even if the even if the player is
right like
and they just have to continue the game
it's just the way that it is so I I love
that thanks Andrew yeah analogy I know
he's always got good good things to like
get me in perspective
I love it I love a good analogy I love
it yeah so then sounds like even through
that experience you you kind of went
quiet for a little bit you felt like it
went inward but you feel do you feel
like you've kind of come out the other
side of it now because I still see you
staring super vulnerably which most
people don't don't just don't do like
you just share in a different way than
most people I see
yeah I it took me it took me a while
um I was very sort of like
like I was sometimes I was showing up
and you know really sharing about
problems but
I just feel I just I honestly couldn't
articulate it in any way for a long time
I didn't
I think I was a little bit stuck into
like why is this happening to me like a
little bit of like a victim mentality
like
boohoo like why me like my life is just
you know sabotaged everything like I've
just gone backwards like I was really
stuck
um but it really once I started feeling
better
physically and getting my health in
check then I feel like everything else
was like getting ticked off and then I
could slowly be more confident in just
being
myself and sharing my thoughts
um I'm not completely there yet
I only just recently put up a post like
about what I'd been through and
you know it was sort of you know there's
only so much you can say right like in a
short caption
um
but yeah trying to be super vulnerable
and just authentic but also protecting
myself from
people who just want to attack you I to
some degree I have I still think about
those people and I think is this giving
them fuel or is this is this going to
aggravate the situation or I don't even
like thinking about it to be honest
but I think the days that go on I the
less and less that I am thinking like
when I'm ready to post or I want to say
something I want to share something
I'm not pulling it apart as much as I
was like yeah I
you know I have years worth of content
that I had
in in draft mode
that I would go to post and I would just
I'd literally be like shaking like it
was crazy I'd be like I can't like I
just can't you know because I would pull
it apart and I would just think it was
just pointless I honestly thought that
everything that I did was just so stupid
so like why am I yeah letting other
people's opinions like
because I think you know like during the
black life medicine it was I remember I
this one like particular moment and I
just posted I think this was very early
on like in the movement and
I posted a juice photo
and then I just had all these people
like
you know who gives a f about you juice
like people are dying
you know you're so privileged to drink
your juice in the car you know in your
in your fancy car and
you know all this and I was just like I
didn't actually even know what was going
on I'm not one to follow the news I
don't listen to the news channels I
don't even scroll through my feed half
of the time
so I was like what okay what's going on
um
and then it just the bowl just rolled
from there it was just a constant attack
like oh you post these food photos like
there's so many bigger things going on
in the world like
you know it's so pointless like actually
do something with your life like
and then because it was just so
consistent like every day it would come
every time I would post I was like
is am I really that pointless am I
really
like is this am I I just couldn't
I just didn't have his Clear Vision of
like who I was anymore I just was
thinking about how other people viewed
me
which I didn't ever really used to think
like that like
I didn't used to do things for
validation or to please others I just
did it because it felt good for me I
just got stuck in my head of like how
does someone else perceive me how does
um you know how does this look to those
people who are going through hardship
and I just felt like everything I did
was offensive to them because it was
it was like if I was going through
something what if I was doing something
good
I was like oh so I'm I'm able to do
something good with my day and these
other people are suffering
and it felt like unfair I wanted them to
have a good life I wanted them to go I I
didn't want them to be hurting and and
so yeah like I said in turn I end up
sabotaging my own life to
so that I didn't you know so so I didn't
live a good life so that I was
sharing their pain to some degree
what's the point of that
yeah oh you should listen to my uh
episode you might have already listened
to it the one with um my friends cat and
Heather on mind change
she talked about yeah she talked about
that about how like yeah there was a
whole section in our conversation where
she was talking about when we take on
other people's feelings and if that's
really a productive or helpful like
there's a difference between caring
about the other versus like taking on
the other so that was an interesting
perspective
and how was
how was Pete with you through all of
this like how has your relationship been
with his like is his like his support
with you through what you have gone
through
it's very supportive
um I think just
you know it was it was blind it
blindsided him too like he had no idea
that that was all those things were
going to happen to me you know
um which is why when I looked back on
this photo in January 2020 I was like
this was really like the last time I
felt like I can recognize that was the
last time I I felt like a normally
shorter person like and before all these
things happened and you know he had no
idea I had no idea so I think he was
trying to juggle it just like I was and
at the same time obviously I'm still a
mum I'm still I have you know money to
make he still has his business like life
still goes on
um but there were times where it was
definitely really hard for him he'd
never ever ever seen me
like
want to give up like want to give up
just want to stop
like I guess and if it was that if that
was
fun the other way and I saw him
declining that way like how scary that
would be
um
so I know it was really scary for him he
was like what is going on with you like
and for the most part I and I still
remember the conversation this was like
getting to like middle of 2020 and like
we sat down and he's like
what's the plan to improve what's like
we need to have a goal or something
because
like you just can't keep living like
this like you know you're crying
yourself to sleep having intense panic
attacks
um just living with anxiety not wanting
like canceling even though everything
was canceled right 2020 but like
canceling everything on top of that
um
you know ghosting everyone not speaking
to anyone
um
you know physically being sick like just
just just yeah so he struggled but he
ultimately gave me the ultimate support
that what a partner should have like
should give and
he was just there for me
um
and yeah he did like I remember when we
had the conversation he's like what are
you gonna do and the first thing I said
which is probably the first time I said
it to him was I need to remove my
implants
and he was like oh like what do you like
why is that like the number one thing
and I said
because I honestly think they're making
me really sick and they're adding
they're heightening everything else
that's going on because I it's making me
sick and it's making me like it's my
brain is not right because I because of
this that's just the way that I feel and
I think that I'm taking on everything
10 times as as bad as it is it's like 10
times worse to me because of this and
then he was like oh like but why do you
think and I was like well I don't know
maybe they're leaking Maybe
I don't know maybe I don't know what it
is I just want to take him out and he
was like that was really the first time
that he come to terms with like that's
what we need to do and then we were like
okay well it's all locked down with all
these restrictions how are we gonna
have a surgery
and you know put it put away like
make the budget happen to have a major
surgery like that
um so that was the first thing I did and
you know he was nothing but supportive
through that whole thing that was like
because we knew that that would take
weeks like I'd probably
be in bed for at least a week and
what I really wanted to give myself at
least a week where I didn't have to do
any of my duties like I didn't have to
make food for the kids I didn't have to
do anything for school I didn't have to
do any homeschooling I just could sleep
and go to the hospital have my surgery
I mean and sure enough I had to I was at
the hospital for like six days because I
just had terrible reactions to the drugs
that I'm just sensitive obviously
but
um yeah I just don't react well to an
anesthetic of any kind and my blood
pressure was extremely low and
um the pain medication the plexia they
gave me I had a full-on trip
I was hallucinating seeing like snakes
come up through the carpet and I thought
that like I could hear every dead person
that had died in the hospital it was
whoa he was horrific I was like oh my
god what have you just given me so that
was an allergic reaction
um to that
so yeah
once I got out
yeah it was a it was about a week in bed
and then I then I slowly got better but
he's just been amazing
um just to give me that support through
and if this wasn't just weeks you know
this was like
this was like a year like a year and a
half of me trying to sort my life out
and he just had to witness it really and
just be the best support that he could
he can be pretty firm at times too like
which is what I needed as well he's like
you know like you need to get out of bed
and you need to like you need to get
going like do not give up we don't give
up
you know because he could see me just
drifting like into that mental state
um I guess of like just that victim
mentality of just like
thinking that nothing could get better
um and he just literally just pulled me
out of that hole and he's like stood me
on my feet you know and he's like you
just
you do it no matter how you feel you do
it wow so a couple of things I want to
say like in response and then I have a
question about this then this part about
relationships because
listening to your story people who are
listening I feel like what we can take
away from this is like you never know
what somebody's going through on online
like you could see their their page or
whatever and even someone who is as
vulnerable as you are online you still
don't really fully know what someone's
going through and to just have a little
bit
of love you know when you look at any
person and that could be even for me
that's a reminder for me when I get even
messages or comments that are quite
nasty like I honestly just feel bad for
the person like I'm like sad like what
are what are you going through that
you're sitting behind a screen right now
wanting to spend your time in this way
and just feeling I don't know just like
taking everything with and understanding
that like everybody's going through
something different and we don't
understand what someone else is going
through to just have a little heart
before you like say something online to
someone else and maybe ask yourself
yeah maybe ask yourself if you would say
this to the person's face you know
that's right that's right I mean I I've
thought that since I was a young child
because my mum really instilled that in
me like you know if you wouldn't say it
to their face don't say it at all you
know or if you don't have anything nice
to say don't say it at all right which
is probably I mean I guess I am quite
reserved in terms of like conflict and
like putting people in their place or
defending myself even I don't tend to do
that because I just
I'm like well it's not going to come out
that nicely even though you've not said
something nice to me
but so I just tend to just be reserved
and just keep it to myself and I'll just
Journal it you know and just let it go
but I also think that's a real blessing
because I just don't take a lot of
things personally for the most part like
for most of my life I've really not
taken many things personally and I'm
very forgiving and I you know forgive
and forget and move on and I think that
people can change and I think
just so many positive things and I just
think that is a good thing about myself
but there there's many times online
where like I do or even in person like I
would like to defend myself
but I don't really like arguing and I I
don't know I just feel like am I is that
like I'm just trying to prove my worth
like I don't know it's weird I'm just
kind of like that just kind of just
leave well whatever let them think
whatever they want
do I have to justify and argue with them
when they probably won't see it anyway
time will just time will tell you know
time will prove that
I'm kind of the opposite where I'm like
let's have this conversation and I like
yeah but if it's online I just know I'm
like I don't have the energy or the
space to give this person I've never met
before or seen before and just spread my
energy on the phone because it's I know
the type of person that I am that when I
take the time to respond to somebody's
criticism negativity nastiness whatever
which every once in a while I do if I'm
in like the very perfect headspace and
I'm like I'm saying you do it and you do
it so well like I've said to you you're
so good with your with your words and
you articulate your arguments in such a
peaceful
factual way that it's like
you just don't even have anything to
come back you're like yeah you're right
but the pro but the problem is is that
in order for me to get that across I
have to spend a lot of time and energy
sitting by myself in a room making sure
I'm saying things exactly how I mean it
like I'm not the type of person to just
like send like I'm not gonna read
through it make sure I want because I
want what I'm going to say to be as well
received as possible yeah yeah right and
the goal is peace conclusion seeing each
other's perspective you know at least
most the time
um but like I said I there's very little
time in my life that I want to dedicate
to that especially for someone that I
don't know and I'm never gonna see in
real life so if it was someone in my
real life though I 100 will always
that's just my personal I'll always meet
you there and want to talk about it but
not everybody wants to do that too you
know like some people might have it the
opposite personality but yeah
we could talk about anything we could
talk about some of our biggest
differences and and still will be
friends right but like some people just
cannot
speak like they just cannot talk about
their own flaws they don't see any any
part of their impact on a situation and
if there's no accountability and you
can't really just reflect on both sides
then how is there even a conclusion
anyway like if it's just one-sided
yeah and also I don't understand talking
to people like that are just one-sided
and just think that yeah you're the
person wrong
yeah absolutely and then just also being
understanding that if someone in your
life is having a really hard time having
talking to you about something that you
guys disagree with like that could also
be because they're just having a lot of
anxiety about it and they haven't worked
through that to be able to even talk to
someone else about something that they
disagree with and maybe it was the way
that they were raised where they were
punished or shamed for disagreeing with
their parents about anything and so like
all those everything's interconnected
anyway so the last the last thing I want
to touch on with what you said about you
know Pete being there for you and stuff
like do do you have like a philosophy on
partnering in love like what is the way
that you guys keep yourselves solid
together even through hard times
yeah I think
you know I've not super like analyzed
our relationship I think because it's
been
we seem to just work like on a lot of
levels
you know a lot of people don't believe
in like astrology and the stars and all
that sort of stuff but in terms of our
astrology like we are perfectly aligned
he's a Virgo I'm a Capricorn
um even like he's he's Moon he's my is
Capricorn and mine is Capricorn as well
um but I think so that's sort of like
the first part of like I think why we
were even attracted to each other in the
first place
um I'm very attracted to like a
go-getter like someone who just gets at
it you know and he's a real like manly
like guy like he just he wants something
he'll just go and get it Andrew is a
Virgo too and he is the same way
oh wow he goes logo man
um
you know so
yeah I think our compatibility there was
was always there from the start you know
but I think in terms of going through
this like roller coaster of relationship
and like love and then you know raising
a family and Parenthood together there's
a lot of challenges that come with that
but ultimately I guess communication
is key like if there's something that's
just niggling and it's consistent it
needs to be addressed and um sometimes
bringing it up isn't always comfortable
and it's not always convenient but like
to say it but just just try and never
deliver it in an attacking way and try
not to be you know overly judgmental and
um
to you know just come from a place of
like how it makes you feel not like you
did this to me or like it's a like
they're directly trying to hurt you or
anything like that it's just like
because they're just so many people just
not aware right of the things that they
do
um especially when you're super busy
right
um we
one of the most amazing things I think
of why we have such a solid relationship
all this time later is
I mean he's amazing with
vacations right and we go out for dinner
and we'll have these amazing weekends
away or it might not be very frequent
but when it is it's just it's so
meaningful and long-lasting
um and that's it's something that's so
important to him to like remove himself
from you know just your daily
environment and go and do something
amazing like go somewhere beautiful
spend it with someone that you love like
take the time
just like you know you guys had that
weekend away and um but we'll try not to
wait that many years to do it we'll try
and do it at least like once a year
um and then you know little date nights
and stuff in between we don't have a lot
of support with family or babysitters
close to us so it does have to be super
planned
um but I think we just make the most of
it but in terms of our home life
you know we both sort of know that like
during the day we just we're working
both of us or we're doing our duties but
then at night
you know we just try and get into bed
early and just like spend that time
together
and that's really where our time is like
it's at night time but I also get up I
get up at 4 45 with him almost every
single day and you know I want him to
feel like
that like we're a team at these things
even though like we have separate jobs
and we have we do a lot of separate
things like I'm super I support you like
and I think because nutrition and health
and wellness is so important to me
um it's something that I want to give to
him so when I get up
at you know the crack of dawn I make his
lunch and I'll make him a hot chocolate
and I'll give him his food for the day
so it just takes a stress it's just one
stress of him that he doesn't have to
think about and I know that like I've
I've sort of played a part in his day
even though I'm not with him and that
means so much to him you know when I was
unwell and I wasn't doing that
it really like caused a bit of like
distance between us like when I wasn't
getting up and I I wasn't seeing him in
the morning and I wasn't giving him that
you know that sort of those like a good
buy like when he would like I walk out
to the like it's dark at the moment you
know I walk out in the dark in the
driveway and waving goodbye and like I
really just give him that energy just
like like I love you I hope you have a
good day like I hope that everything
goes well with you today and you know
I'll see you when you get home like
I think the energy that you that you
sort of project onto your partner is
important even like if it's not if it's
like that invisible like if you just
love them and you want the best for them
like just really
like give them that that give them that
energy like give them that Vibe even if
they know it or not it's like like you
think it tastes like I love you so much
I'm so proud of you I'm
so grateful for you like I think all
those things like in the mornings even
though sometimes we might not speak I'm
because I'm doing those things with
intention and that's how I feel so that
hopefully he might feel that that way
about me and that way about us and
yeah so I think too with the kids
our kids are really great sleepers in
terms of they go to bed and they sleep
all night
and they're in their room
when there was times when like if
they've been sick or when they were
young and there was kind of like a bit
of they were sleeping in our room or in
our bed that caused a bit of
um distance between us because we
couldn't connect
so I think that's a really important
thing and I think when I speak to other
parents
and they're like oh you know our three
or four-year-olds like still sleeping in
our bed and or I sleep in the eldest
child's room and then the other child
sleeps with the dad in the room and I
know that like for a short periods of
time that definitely has to happen
but I think it can get too
consistent and too comfortable like that
and it can last for years yeah and then
if you're not connecting with your
partner for years
but I mean what do you think's like
gonna happen like at some point you're
just not going to feel like
in that relationship like yeah you you
your roommates and you're doing life
together and you're just doing
Parenthood together but if you're not
like physically connecting emotionally
connecting to them
because you don't have the time because
you always have this child like wedged
in between you at all times for years on
end yeah and then you don't take times
to have date nights you don't take time
to go away together
um you don't take time to like have
small breaks at home like you know just
let we also have a lot of space here
right let the kids run go play on the
trampoline go run around the yard and
like me and Dad can just sit here and
have a chat and if they come up and want
to keep distracting us we just say like
Mom and Dad are just having you know a
few minutes together we'd really
appreciate if you could just go and play
and you know you've got all these this
beautiful space and just come back in 10
minutes you know and most of the time
they are pretty understanding
it's just sort of goes back to like
those small things that you do
throughout the day to make a massive
difference in an outcome
yeah those boundaries I think are really
helpful with kids and also good for them
because you know Scout my daughter was
asking like why do you have why are you
leaving you know when we were going to
go on our two night away I think we're
like it's kind of like how I take you on
a date and it's really nice to be alone
together sometimes with nobody else like
me and Dad need that too we need to be
able to be alone together and so the
same thing for us when the kids go to
bed it's like it's bedtime you're going
to bed in your room so me and Dad can
connect by ourselves and that's hard for
them to understand sometimes but just
being that example and showing them how
important and integral it is to like
keep your relationship connected that
way and like you said about what you're
doing in the morning for him showing him
love the way that he's gonna receive it
best I think goes a long way and I think
our love languages are quite similar
like acts of service
um we're both similar in that sense so
like I do
so much for him just as much as I
possibly can and he is the same so we're
not really left feeling like oh I wish
they did more of this or
more of that because we both recognize
that like I recognize that he feels very
loved when I'm doing those things being
like when I am making his food when
um you know I do give him affection and
you know scratch his back and his
physical charge is very important to him
and I understand that and I think that's
the way that I'm always naturally been
so you know it just brings us closer
like when we're in bed we're not
just stuck on our phones like in other
worlds we're like together and even if I
am if I have to be on my phone or he has
to be on the phone we're still kind of
like touching each other in some degree
like I'll have my hand on his chest or
like on his backs rushing his back or
touching his head like he knows that I'm
there and like
um and and vice versa so you know it's
not like there's this distance like
you know between us like we're just
laying but like I quote I can't stand
that you know feeling like you're
together but you're not together like
I've had that in past relationships and
it's just
who wants to share a bed with like this
you feel like a stranger like someone
you don't fully know or can't be
yourself with or talk with so
um and one more thing I think too is
staying in good physical health
because
it's something that I recognize in a lot
of other
people too that like when you let
yourself go and then as much as people
say oh like I'll love you anyway right
but if you don't if you're not
physically attracted to them because
they've let themselves go so much that
they literally don't
respect their own physical body
that may not be attractive to you
anymore and then
what happens then then maybe you won't
connect maybe you won't be having
intimacy
and then if you're not having intimacy
then you don't have that intimate
connection emotionally with them and
then you just become
roommates you just become just parents
to your children and that's really the
only reason why you may stay together
but it just it's just like this Slow
Divide so I think
when you feel super well in your body
and you feel confident and and
comfortable with yourself that you you
you're like an open book you know you're
an Open Door you will just let that
person just see you exactly the way that
you are and because you love who you are
already and you're comfortable in that
skin like the amount of other mums that
I've spoken to that
like they really don't like their bodies
at all and like I hate this I hate this
I hate this like oh you know my
partner's not seeing me with with with
the lights on in years you know or wow
how can you be
like in that pure state of intimacy if
you don't even want to see you
right like how are they going to see
like if you don't want to see your sh
it's such an energy thing too like
you're already shut out before you even
get under the covers right yeah it was a
lot yeah
yeah totally a lot of times those
insecurities aren't even really based
into reality but it's how we perceive
ourself
yeah
and that could be and that could be
partly because of the Social Media stuff
and like face filters and all these
things that make everyone look like
these fake versions of themselves that
isn't reality and then that affects how
you feel about yourself yeah yeah I love
it overly affected by that like
that I've never really used face filters
and all that sort of stuff like
all the weird things that people
do but
um it's never bothered me like I've
never really had issues with wanting to
be someone else or anything like that
um but in terms of
relationship I think and connection with
someone else is just um it's just
important to
just love who who you are and like what
you see in the mirror the person that
you that how you carry yourself like
whether it's with your partner or like
how do you how do you treat other people
like how do you think other people
perceive you like how do you want them
to remember you like if that's the first
time you're ever going to see someone
the last time
like are you gonna have good energy like
do you feel confident and good in
yourself
um you know and every relationship goes
through challenges like I remember when
I told him I well I had to I had to get
my implants removed and I knew that
right like we both loved them to some
degree like they were attractive and
they're very sexual and you feel very
feminine
um
and it was a big part of like our sexual
connection was
this area of my body not not just for
him like for me too so I think
that's why it was sort of like a big
decision too I was like it wasn't just
about me I knew that this was a part
that that would be difficult for him but
he never
he never ever said like no or you need
to get you need to get them pulled back
in or like he never made me feel like
what I naturally was was not going to be
enough which just you know I just
invalidates that person that I know that
he is like he's he's just so beautiful
like that and I know that like when we
first got together I didn't have them
and
um
he you know he loved me the way that I
was then and I loved me too the same way
so it was a little bit of like just
getting used to it like once they were
they were out like just getting used to
it and I had put on a lot of weight too
like you know it was sort of close to 20
kilos there for a while like I was I
look like a different person honestly in
the mirror I was like I don't know I
can't recognize myself
um so being a little bit intimate like
at times was a little bit hard like just
to be so exposed feeling like I was just
a different person but he still accepted
me and he never made me feel less or he
never compared me to
another girl or and like what I should
look like he just let we both just sort
of let that Journey happen and I mean I
had some major insecurities at a point I
I did I was like because I just didn't
think I was going to get back to normal
I was like am I just going to be
like just feeling gross like
forever and you know and the first time
I was ever insecure around him
um you know like we I didn't want to put
a bikini on like we're at the beach and
I felt so uncomfortable I was like I've
never felt
this industry never in my life like wow
feeling insecure like I'd never felt
that and um and then I felt like oh my
God like he's looking at these girls on
the beach and they just look so much
better and I was putting that thought
like thinking that's what he was
thinking but he wasn't even thinking
that yeah well honestly because that's
what I was thinking right right well I'm
so glad that you had that you have a
partner that was able to ground you
through those insecurities and wasn't
like exasperating it because he wasn't
what you were kind of making in your
head
yeah because I thought oh it's easier
right if someone else thinks that and
it's their insecurity you know because
they're not happy with you but it was me
like I wasn't happy with with myself at
that time and I was insecure and that's
my visualizations and it was nothing
that he that he did it was just like
it was just a projection
right well I feel like your story is
really hopeful for like it can be for
somebody who's like maybe listening
going through a dark time and seeing all
the ups and downs that you've had and
what you've come through like where are
you now like kind of coming rounding out
this conversation where do you feel like
you're at now you just went to a retreat
I saw you share a little bit about like
how you're feeling now in this time
period
um and like what are you most excited
about now that I think that's like my
last question for you like what where
are you at right now and what are you
most excited about
I'm I'm overall I think the word is like
is like positive and moving forward I
just I feel
confident in my in in myself I I can
feel changes I can see changes I've
witnessed you know a transformation over
the last couple of years
um and I just I'm really validated that
I've just done the right things and um
you know the retreat I did on the
weekend was you know it was just a two
day two and a half day retreat but my
gosh it did it made an impact it was
felt like it was weeks it was I had not
taken
time for myself
like I couldn't even tell you actually
the last time and I just happened to be
like it was for work you know I was
invited there
um but I realized
just how important and I should have
done that months ago for myself like I
shouldn't have waited for someone to
invite me to do that
um and that's also why I wanted to
really share that message like any mums
out there like anyone who just go and do
it like make the time to do it so I
think moving forward I just I just want
to keep sharing
um just the way that I you know I have
been and just really getting to the flow
of sharing again
I am working on a few different books I
haven't really like nailed just working
on one
um I sort of worked on like a breast
implant illness book
um just sort of like my journey how it
came about the sort of the facts on
breast implantis itself and then the the
journey to like how to even think about
like having surgery and
processes there and taking like getting
ready and preparing yourself for surgery
and the healing time after it and then
detoxing after
um and then a kid's book I'm working on
a kids book I love that
yeah so there's a few few things in the
works I just I haven't really nailed
like yeah just like this is exactly what
I'm doing and this is the only thing I'm
focusing on because I'm really only just
getting that clarity now
um my focus is just still so much just
about raising the kids and being a mom
and that's my number one
um like keeping a household like
um that's just what I I do love to do
and that's what I do every day and my
work is like is kind of it is like
number two I mean it's even number three
because like my relationship is up there
you know with my partner
um but I think I need to create a little
bit more structure like a little bit
more boundaries around work and I know
we need to have that conversation
because you are so amazing at that and
the way that you just put that structure
around your family life and work balance
you know I know you also struggle with
it like it's very hard and to have the
kids understand is probably the hardest
part like creating boundaries around
like mummies working like at the moment
like this morning I just needed to do a
post right and it's like like I was up
at 4 45 my son was up at five like he
was with me we were for hours of playing
Scrabble we put the fire on like we were
doing lots of things and I'm like I just
need 10 minutes buddy just need 10
minutes because I you know this is work
I need to put this post up in that and
because I wanted to as well like I love
using that stuff yeah and um I tend to I
have pretty much hidden that part of my
life from the kids it's like
when I'm with them I'm not on my phone
when I'm with them I'm not doing work
but like I'm with them a lot as well
like
how can I create
more
um awareness for them and that like
I'm like Mommy's working Mommy's doing
something I'll be with you
you know but I think because I haven't
really done that they don't understand
you know and they think oh it's rude
like how rude of you to be on your phone
for 10 minutes and not play Lego with me
um
but not feeling guilty about it too
because you know I watch I watch Peter
and like
it's so clear like his boundaries are so
clear and the kids just
yeah it's just black and white
Dad's on the phone if I'm on the phone
they're climbing on my head they're like
I know
like they're going nuts and I just why
is it that he they'll do it for him but
they won't do it for me and I think I
think because naturally being female
we're so adaptable and
um agreeable and we just kind of go with
the flow because it's just for over
changing right but yeah I think you're
just creating some clips with a lot of
things and structure will help me
move forward and and um
just keep on this
incline that I'm on and I'm feeling
amazing my health is just flourishing at
the moment and um it's sort of like it's
showing like in in all areas like it's
finally like I finally feel like my body
is just balancing out my hormones are
good like my hair's growing back my
mental health is just phenomenal
like to trigger me into anxiety is
pretty it's like hard to do like
it which is amazing because I feel like
I could just be triggered by anything so
I'm I'm really happy with where
I'm so happy for you I'm so happy to
hear that and I think that's really
inspiring and helpful and I'm just so
glad we had this conversation because I
just love everything you share I love
our conversations and I hope people
really enjoyed our little conversation
thanks for taking the time to do this
yeah I know I know it's both it's hard
for both of us but we made it happen we
did even afterwards yeah we had so many
times we've got difficulties we got
there yeah we got there in the end so
I'm I'm super happy too and um you know
hopefully this is one of many and you
know we can continue like a bit of a
series of conversations because I feel
like we just can talk about so many
different subjects I know that is good
for other people to hear because it
comes from like a place of like this
common ground or you know and not um and
not a right or wrong like it's it's very
like an understanding so yeah yes I love
it yes I agree I would love that Alani
and Ellen series we need to do it you're
gonna come to Hawaii next time I think
yes and you need to come to Australia oh
I would love to do that oh my gosh just
the thought though of getting all five
kids to Australia just sounds like way
too much
I know I've been watching stories and
I'm like how does she travel with all of
those kids she's amazing she's about
she's like superhuman she's so amazing
yeah and their family is amazing so
awesome maybe she's on she's on the list
for an interview
oh yeah one day when her life like slows
down a little bit yeah yeah ah yes well
cool thank you so much Lonnie this was
amazing and thank you Ellie you share
your story yeah
thanks for having me and thanks for the
chat and um we'll speak soon and bye
everyone who's listening I don't really
want it yeah
I know I'm always like thanking people
if you get this far thank you for tuning
in this part
[Music]